Transcription: eric vautier
Relecteur: Claire Ghyselen
Chacun son truc.
Il y en a qui aiment croire aux OVNI,
pour d’autres,
c’est le monstre du Loch Ness.
Vous avez l’astrologie, la voyance,
les reptiliens, la Terre plate.
Il y a aussi la légende
de la croissance verte.
Celle-là, elle fait fureur
chez les économistes.
La croissance verte,
c’est cette théorie qu’on peut
à la fois toujours produire plus
tout en polluant moins.
Donc pas besoin de se limiter
car la croissance dans les pays riches
serait devenue dématérialisée,
sobre, propre, en un mot, verte.
Cette histoire, on l'entend partout.
Le problème,
c’est que c’est faux.
D’abord, l’erreur c’est de penser
qu’il suffit de décarboner.
Mais pour une véritable
transition écologique,
nous avons besoin de baisser
énormément de choses :
usages de l’eau, pollution de l’air,
de l’eau, production de déchets,
impact sur la biodiversité,
empreinte matière.
Aucune économie n'a réussi à faire baisser
cette empreinte écologique totale
tout en faisant croître son économie.
Les seuls moments où on s’en est approché,
c’était pendant des récessions.
Le deuxième point, c’est de se dire
que cette empreinte écologique totale,
elle dépasse largement les frontières.
C’est facile
de verdir l’économie française
si vous venez délocaliser les industries
les plus polluantes à l’étranger.
Et d’ailleurs, regardons
les gaz à effet de serre.
En France, plus de la moitié
de notre empreinte carbone,
ce sont des émissions importées.
Une fois que vous commencez à réduire,
ce n’est pas fini.
Il faut réduire suffisamment vite
et de manière suffisamment importante
pour revenir sous le seuil
des limites planétaires.
Ça aussi, cela n'a jamais été fait.
Les seuls moments
où on a réussi à commencer,
c’était pendant des périodes
de croissance négative.
Ce qui montre bien que,
quelle que soit la réduction
qu’on a réussi à avoir
pendant des périodes de croissance
ou de stagnation,
on pourrait avoir une réduction
plus rapide et plus importante
si l’on venait réduire la production.
Donc, cette théorie de la croissance
verte est factuellement fausse,
mais elle est aussi
politiquement dangereuse.
La croissance verte,
c’est le discours climato-rassuriste
du moment,
une sorte de greenwashing macro-économique
qui permet aux pays riches
de se dédouaner de leur responsabilité
dans la crise écologique.
C’est une sorte de carte joker
utilisée à foison
par des entreprises et des gouvernements
qui l’utilisent
pour justifier leur inaction.
« Ne vous inquiétez pas,
l’économie est en train de se verdir.
Ça va arriver, il n’y a qu’à attendre. »
Ça fait 20 ans qu’on attend
et l’économie n’est toujours pas verdie.
Si vous avez 40 de fièvre,
que vous êtes au fond du lit
et que vous attendez que le Père Noël
vous apporte des médicaments,
vous allez être déçu.
Croissance sobre, croissance verte,
croissance bleue,
croissance dématérialisée,
les économistes adorent
parler de croissance.
Le problème, c’est qu’ils ne nous
disent jamais ce que c’est.
Je vous dis « Croissance »,
vous allez me dire « Bien-être,
modernité, innovation, civilisation. »
Mais ce n'est pas ça la croissance.
La croissance économique, c’est
spécifique, c’est l’augmentation du PIB.
Le P I B : Produit intérieur brut.
Un indicateur d’agitation monétaire,
une sorte de podomètre géant
qui vient compter les euros
produits dans votre économie.
Par exemple,
vous payez un publicitaire pour
faire des pubs pour les burgers :
salaire, PIB en hausse.
Cette pub, ça va inciter
à la consommation de burgers - PIB.
Certains d’entre vous vont tomber malades
et devoir aller chez le médecin - PIB.
Il va recommander d’acheter
des médicaments - PIB.
Vous allez les chercher en voiture au
centre commercial : PIB, PIB, PIB, PIB.
Le problème : il n’y a pas de différence
entre le néfaste et le désirable.
C’est une calculatrice
avec une seule touche : un gros +.
Ça ne prend pas en compte
la qualité de ce qui est produit
et encore moins le bien-être
qu’on en retire.
Mesurer la prospérité en points de PIB,
c’est un peu comme mesurer
le bonheur en kilomètres.
Imaginons qu’on n’ait pas
fait de pub pour les burgers.
On n’aurait pas surconsommé de
burgers, on ne serait pas tombé malade,
on aurait dégorgé les salles
d’attente des médecins,
on n’aurait pas eu besoin
de produire les médicaments,
pas eu besoin de prendre la voiture.
Et ce pauvre publicitaire
aurait pu faire quelque chose
de plus utile de son temps.
Résultat des courses :
on serait en meilleure santé,
on n’aurait pas besoin d’argent
pour payer ce surcroît de burgers
et tous les problèmes qui vont avec.
On serait dans une situation
où on aurait moins de points de PIB,
mais on serait
dans une meilleure situation sociale.
Là en fait, on se rend compte
que la croissance économique,
c’est un peu comme un tapis de course :
on a l’impression d’avancer,
mais on s’épuise à faire du surplace.
On épuise nos écosystèmes
et on s’épuise nous-mêmes,
tout ça pour accumuler des points
de PIB dans des pays déjà riches
où le PIB par habitant est décorrélé
des indicateurs de qualité de vie.
Mais on continue quand même à s’entêter
à faire grossir nos économies.
La vraie question n’est pas :
comment verdir la croissance ?
c’est : avons-nous vraiment besoin
de continuer à croître ?
Et plus fondamentalement,
comment découpler
bien-être
et pression sur l’environnement ?
Vous préférez avoir
une économie de croissance
qui cherche aveuglément
à accumuler des points de PIB,
ou une économie du contentement
qui cherche à satisfaire des besoins ?
Je sais ce que vous allez dire - là,
c’est le moment où je me fais insulter :
zadiste anti-progrès, punks [anarchiste]
rétrograde, collapso-communiste,
ou le pire du pire :
décroissant.
Celle-là, elle est dure.
Mais j'ai l'habitude.
J’ai écrit une thèse
et un livre sur le sujet,
je me suis dit que j’allais quand même
apporter une définition.
Pour contextualiser,
quand on dit décroissance,
souvent c’est pour critiquer cette
hégémonie de la croissance économique
et c’est pour justifier
de la nécessité d’organiser -
attention, c’est là que
la définition commence -
« une réduction de la production
et de la consommation
pour alléger l’empreinte écologique
planifiée démocratiquement
dans un esprit de justice sociale
et dans le souci du bien-être. »
La décroissance, c’est une sorte de
grand régime macroéconomique
pour des pays
en situation d’obésité écologique.
Si vous n’arrivez pas à verdir
votre production, ou pas assez vite,
ou pas pour tout,
il va falloir la réduire.
Mais attention à l’amalgame
entre décroissance et récession.
La récession, c'est l'accident économique.
Elle n’est pas prévue,
elle n’est pas désirable.
Et elle se fait souvent
dans la panique et la douleur.
Alors que la décroissance,
c’est un projet de transition.
On la prépare, on la discute et on fait
en sorte qu’elle soit juste et conviviale.
Récession.
Décroissance.
Deux salles, deux ambiances.
Assimiler un changement
de système complexe à une récession
juste parce que les deux
font baisser le PIB,
c’est comme assimiler un régime
à une amputation parce que les deux
provoquent une perte de poids.
Perso, si je dois perdre 20 kilos,
je préfère manger moins de burgers
que de me scier la jambe.
Eh bien, c’est pareil.
Si on doit perdre
en empreinte écologique totale,
autant s’organiser intelligemment
pour que ça se passe le mieux possible.
Mais la décroissance n’est pas
seulement un rétrécissement,
c’est aussi un changement
de logiciel économique.
Au lieu de maximiser des indicateurs
financiers, PIB pour les gouvernements,
profits pour les entreprises,
revenus pour les individus,
on viendrait satisfaire
des indicateurs socio-écologiques.
Les gouvernements préserveraient
des budgets bien-être.
Les entreprises poursuivraient
des utilités sociales
et les individus amélioreraient
un pouvoir de vivre.
Fini la logique de la maximisation,
on passe à celle du contentement.
Objectif : satisfaire les besoins de tous
sans dépasser nos plafonds écologiques.
On passe d’une production
par les prix et pour les profits
à une production par les besoins
et pour le bien-être.
Et c’est le projet de la post-croissance.
La post-croissance, c’est un concept
qu’on utilise pour faire référence
à l’idéal d’une société émancipée
de ses impératifs financiers.
C’est une société qui aurait une économie
stationnaire, en harmonie avec la nature,
où les décisions sont prises ensemble,
où les richesses sont équitablement
partagées afin de pouvoir prospérer
sans croissance.
Si la décroissance
est un régime temporaire
pour perdre du poids écologique,
la post-croissance est
le maintien sur le long terme
d’un mode de production sain et équilibré.
Petite précision.
Quand je vous dis « post-croissance »,
ça veut nécessairement dire
« post-capitalisme ».
Le capitalisme
ne peut ni organiser
sa propre décroissance,
ni prospérer sans croissance.
C’est un système accumulatif
qui ne sait pas s’arrêter.
La seule chose que le capitalisme
ne peut pas vendre, c'est rien.
C’est un peu comme les requins,
ils doivent constamment avancer
pour respirer.
Le mode de production capitaliste,
pour pouvoir se stabiliser,
doit constamment produire.
Quel que soit le nom qu’on lui donne,
cette économie qu’on doit inventer,
elle va devoir être post-capitaliste.
Mais ce n'est pas tout.
Il va aussi falloir redéfinir une relation
respectueuse avec le vivant.
Il va falloir réinventer des définitions
de la prospérité, des richesses.
Il va falloir changer notre relation,
notre vision du travail,
notre rapport au temps.
Il va falloir redonner
de l’importance à la solidarité
et à l’entraide.
Le message à faire passer ici
aux économistes
et à tous ceux qui les écoutent -
il y en a beaucoup -
c’est que réinventer l’économie de demain,
ce n’est pas un QCM
avec seulement deux options :
capitalisme ou communisme.
Tout est possible.
C’est d’ailleurs assez paradoxal
parce que’aujourd’hui,
on a ce culte de l’entrepreneur,
ces personnes qui
think outside of the box,
think different,
move fast and break things.
Mais si quelqu’un lève la main pour
proposer un système économique alternatif,
on l’insulte d’Amish
nostalgique des charrettes.
On a l’impression de vivre dans une
société progressiste et dynamique,
mais en fait, on est enfermé
dans le présent.
Nous sommes confinés à l'intérieur
de notre propre système.
Si quelqu’un essaie
de changer quelque chose,
dès que quelqu’un a une bonne
idée qui sort de l’ordinaire,
vous avez un économiste qui va arriver
avec son tableau Excel pour lui dire :
« Attention, l’économie, c’est fragile,
il ne faut pas toucher, sinon
[incompris] des marchés va s’effondrer. »
Déjà, neuf fois sur dix, c’est faux.
La véracité des prédictions
des modèles économiques
est à peu près aussi fiable
qu’un jeu de tarot.
Mais ensuite, c’est contreproductif.
Il est dangereux ce récit.
On est en plein milieu d’une crise
civilisationnelle, d’une crise écologique,
et on nous dit : « Attention, ne pas
toucher l’économie, peinture fraîche. »
Il faut se rappeler
Que tout ce qui a été
socialement construit
peut être socialement
déconstruit et reconstruit.
L'économie, c'est une sphère
sociale malléable.
Et le capitalisme est loin d’être
l’Everest de la civilisation humaine.
Donc, il va falloir se mettre au travail.
Et on va devoir commencer
par éduquer notre désir
pour des futurs plus ambitieux
que ce tapis roulant de la croissance
où les rêves de demain sont calculés
en pourcentages des comptes
en banque d’aujourd’hui.
Il est grand temps d'arrêter cette
obsession avec la relance de l'économie
et de commencer systématiquement
à relancer la critique de l’économie.
Il est grand temps qu’on se pilule rouge
en dehors de ce système écocidaire
pour venir inventer une économie
juste, soutenable,
démocratique et conviviale.
Il est grand temps
d’arrêter de prédire
le futur de l’économie
et de commencer à inventer
l’économie du futur.
(Applaudissements)